[Music]
let's go to natasha in mountain home
dude what a cool town hey what's up
natasha
hey how are you thanks for having me
that's cool i like mountain home
mountain home that's like uh never mind
i'm gonna get off i'm gonna get
distracted
we've had some meetings recently where
we've talked about my
distraction uh level so i'm trying to
stay focused so natasha from mountain
home what's up
um well
uh i just wanted some tips i guess on
how to
successfully transition from a
parent who uses spanking as a discipline
method
um you know to a more gentle parenting
method but also you know i feel like
we've kind of set the bar and i don't
really know how do we go back from here
oh man so what what what what got you
rethinking your approach to discipline
um
yeah what got you thinking
i've heard you talk about it before and
i've seen you know some of the research
about it and
i've been interested in it and i try you
know really hard to
with to be as patient and just you know
just implement the gentle discipline you
know in our house but
i feel like like i said we've got the
ball rolling on you know using spanking
already and i don't know how to
how do we go back yeah so man number one
i applaud you for any time any parent
makes any kind of changes whether it's
this one or
um doing anything differently midstream
that's hard right we've created a
context that our kids that's that's what
they know
um and so doing anything differently
like man all we eat is all we eat is his
lucky charms around here and then all of
a sudden you think like nope we're
switching to oatmeal then you're gonna
have a rebellion there for a little bit
right like a mutiny
um all right so i want you to take the
word gentle out of your
vocabulary
not um
gentle isn't what we're aiming for
okay okay i want you to um think of we
are with
not over that's the transition we're
making
okay
um
i am no longer going to try to get you
to do things because i've got bigger
muscles than you
right i'm going to walk alongside you as
i teach you and coach you and instruct
you and hold you
incredibly accountable right which
includes punishment that includes uh
consequences um i'm gonna walk alongside
you as we help you grow up to be
an adult right so here's what i would
recommend
the cornerstone of any sort of
discipline if you will any sort of um
co-responsibility is ownership
the kid has to feel like they are
participating in something bigger than
they are
otherwise they are an actor in your play
they hold no responsibility other than
watch out for swinging fists and sticks
okay
and they will and i'm and you probably
know all this but i'm i'm i wanna
to the people who are listening i wanna
paint a broader picture
that might mean that they go get
straight a's and they're silent and
they're quiet and they sit still
they can do that because they're part of
a family ecosystem that breathes and
that breathes together and leans on one
another
or they can do it to avoid getting hit
right right and i want a kid who when
they're 22 knows i do these things
because that's how a neighborhood
operates that's how my community
operates i play a vital role in making
sure that my country and my neighborhood
and my family is is is doing well it's
healthy right not i want to do these
things so i can avoid fill in the blank
because that leads to all kind of things
downstream so here's what i would
suggest you probably heard me say this
before but this is a good time to
reiterate it
um
let's say
your family is the smiths
i would love to see the smith family get
together
and have a big event
plan it up bake a cake make it a big
thing i want your kids to know you get
and you gotta how old your kid
he's seven seven you have any other kids
yeah we have a two-year-old as well okay
bring him along and let the
seven-year-old know that his
responsibility is helping the
two-year-old participate right so now
he's got a two-fold he's got a job here
right he's vested
and we're going to create a
we're going to go to like michael's
we're gonna go to a hardware store we're
gonna get like a like a piece of plywood
we're gonna get some fancy artsy thing i
don't know i've seen some on the
internet people have sent me and some of
them are beautiful
the one we did in our house isn't that
fancy because i'm not that artistic and
um my wife is much more than me but we
didn't go that route but
we're going to create create a
set of here's who the smith
family is values okay
that will be
you may have some fun with it you're
gonna have a piece of cake you're gonna
laugh you're gonna have a nice dinner
together um is dad around
uh he is but we are actually um
in the process of separating okay all
right so there's gonna be a lot of
additional chaos in your home right your
seven-year-old is going to be
additionally untethered in certain ways
so this can be
one of those steps towards it's not
going to be the solution it's going to
be one of the steps towards keeping him
anchored during this separation which is
going to be it's going to be tough on
them right
right so here's who the smiths are
we treat people with respect we are kind
we turn the tv off
at the first whatever the thing is we
listen to one another we
to do chores to get whatever the
language that's appropriate for the age
and then the transition is this
when you ask your son to do something
okay go pick up your socks and he mouths
off
it is now not you choosing to hit him or
you choosing to
kick him out of the house
you the heartbroken parent
are accepting his choice to no longer be
in the room for the next 10 minutes
you've accepted his choice to not go to
the birthday party this weekend
you've accepted his decision because he
chose to violate the values he got to
choose
not to fill in the blank with whatever
consequences you all decide
it does help if you participate some in
these consequences okay so if you have
ice cream or something dinner and one of
them is we talk with respect and you
yell one day
and give him permission to go ah
right and you go up no ice cream for mom
tonight i chose don't have ice cream
because i chose to yell right let him
see that it's not you versus him y'all
are in this together
and this isn't a
cure-all but this becomes an anchor
point
um
also
if you feel strongly about hey i don't
want to
hit my kid
it's not a bad thing to let your kid
know i'm going to start doing things
differently now
and um
i have i have tried that with him before
and you know
um like doing like you said and you know
letting him know that okay well you know
i'm sorry that you chose this and
it's it's more fun when you're out here
with us and when you can play with us
and we all have more fun when you're
here but he seems to be completely
unfazed like if you you know tell him no
dessert with dinner he's like oh okay
well no dessert if you tell him you
can't play with his legos oh well i'll
just twiddle my thumbs or you know he he
seems so unfazed by by everything
there's always you know some sort of
something else he can do instead and so
it's there's twofold to that number one
good for him
he's
he's that's the leadership man he is
learning i'll trade that for that
fair yeah and if it's something of
consequence
right so we're seeing it play on the
global scale we we said if you're you
um country x are gonna bomb this country
then you'll have no more money we're
gonna take all your money
and they go
that's cool we'll keep bombing and then
it's like well okay then you know so at
some point if it's something that we
care about like loss of life you're
gonna keep upping the ante right i will
find something my mom talks about
she locked me in the house like i got
grounded to my room that was hell for me
it was torture my little brother on the
other hand had to go outside
because he was he liked um reading he
liked he was great with with you know
computer programming he was that kid and
so she had to approach it differently
for both of us but finding things that
were of meaning and of value to us
right um and so that's the best the the
navigation apparent but if a kid decides
to ride it out then the kid's riding it
out
and that means we've got to up the
accountability a little bit and also
i mean let's high five your kid that's
kind of cool too right
uh let's not it's so frustrating because
i love it but i hate it there you go yes
yes it's like when my kid tells a joke
and i'm like you can't say that but that
was really funny you know yes it's like
that um some of that is your kid leaning
on you especially in the season my guess
is if y'all are getting separated now if
things been tough for a season
oh yeah yeah
so um has there been any abuse in the
home or anything like that
no no abuse or anything just we just
can't manage to get along what about
volume been yelling and
things uh yeah there has been okay
so
um
in some regard
your kid is gonna double down your kid's
gonna be willing to take um a few lumps
it's gonna bite himself in the foot to
see if you're gonna hang on to him
yeah is he gonna lose you too
and some of that is um making sure he
not only hears you say but sees
you will never lose me
right and um it may be that time outs or
opting out or something like that isn't
the appropriate response for this season
in fact it may be the opposite fine then
if you talk like that you got to give me
a hug for five minutes an unstopping
five-minute hug
you gotta help mom with her laundry
that's just that's what you chose to do
you know what i mean
i'm gonna i'm gonna bring you even
closer to me
um
you have to go draw a picture in this
book about how great mommy is right i'm
gonna i'm gonna do things that are gonna
bring us closer together than the
opposite but the goal here the
overarching thing is this
i want my child to have ownership in
their choices i'm gonna teach them about
choices and let's not forget that
they're seven
or they're nine and they're twelve
they're not going to do this perfectly
and they will call our bluff over and
over and over and over again and that's
the worst part my mom used to say i
promise you grounding you hurts me more
than you because i can't just leave now
because you're stuck in the house like
it's worse for for me than you um and
sometimes when we're when we are
uh trying to teach our kids
accountability we're trying to teach
them hard work and respect and dignity
all those important things um
man we gotta we take it on the chin by
holding them accountable that's the hard
dirty work of being a parent and um man
your kid is lucky to have you natasha
um
be really graceful with him during this
transition it's going to be hard he's
going to test every boundary he's got to
see if mom's going to leave
to see if um
there's something he can do that you're
going to say we just can't get along
either i guess or that dad's going to
say well you and i son we just can't get
along so we're done he's gonna really
need some extra attention and i would be
direct with your husband about as we
separate here
um if there's no no path for
reconciliation as we separate here
where both of us are going to be
grown-ups about doubling down and making
sure that this little boy this little
baby this little two-year-old are hyper
hyper connected otherwise they will take
this separation on as their problem to
solve and they'll be about solving it
for the rest of their life hey i have a
quick question to jump in with you so
talking to this makes sense with a
seven-year-old as far as younger kids
like i have a three-year-old when you
talk about
the idea of them
understanding that it's their choice
that they made this choice and they're
dealing with the consequences
it feels like it feels like that's gonna
be hard for a two-year-old or
three-year-old to understand so what
does that look like for a younger kid
yeah sometimes um so james thanks for
that um natasha thank you so much for
that call uh james so with a two and
three-year-old
unfortunately it takes a lot of parent
mobility
meaning i'm going to get up and move you
to this place right you may not be able
to walk away or sometimes it is i will
not allow you to hit right so sometimes
we'll tell a kid um
uh
yeah i'm gonna be more imposing on my
my will if you will um a separation for
a three-year-old is
saying the words out loud
when you hit you chose to go sit over
here and not play i'm not you're not
putting you in another room that's
torture for a three-year-old or a
two-year-old but i will put you over
here and that may mean i have to keep
picking you up and putting you back over
here and we're gonna do the minute per
year right you've heard that um you'll
be in this corner for three minutes and
seeing us
um and then the first thing i'm gonna
meet you back there with hugs i'm gonna
make sure you know you're connected
please don't hit please don't choose to
go over here i'm gonna continue to
reiterate that language but you're right
two-year-old doesn't doesn't know that
that where we fall into is we
whap a two-year-old or we swat a
three-year-old
and they don't understand that either
and so there's a it's it's that physical
presence but some of that with a
three-year-old is yeah unfortunately i
got bigger muscles than you you i will
not allow you to hit right and i will
move your body once they get to four
five six seven then they start taking
ownership of that i say to my
six-year-old often
i'm please talk to me about why you're
choosing this response here and if she
can't articulate it she begins she'll go
she'll duck her head and then begin to
smile like i don't i don't know you know
what i mean so i want her to begin to
take ownership but again
she's six seven
five those i mean
there's a reason we don't let them vote